In this problem, a square loop water
distribution network A B C D is supplied
with a flow of 2500 gallons per minute
at point A. All circular pipe segments
have the following properties given in
the table. Outflows are noted at points
B, C, and D.
Ignore minor losses and assume the Hazen
Williams equation is valid for head
loss. Compute the flow correction in
gallons per minute using one iteration
of the Hardy Cross method.
So in this problem we are given a
square loop water distribution network
which we can see displayed over to the
right and we can see that they have the
following properties for each pipe given
in the table. So the properties we have
are
the distances between each point noted A
to B, B to C, C to D and A2D.
We are given the flow rate in gallons
per minute, the C value for the Hazen
Williams equation, the diameter of each
pipe in inches, and the length of each
pipe in feet.
So the first thing we can do is search
for the Hardy Cross method in our
reference manual. The environmental
reference manual will have this in
chapter 1. The Hardy Cross equation is
given as delta Q
equals
negative times the sum
of the head loss
over 1.85
times the sum of the head loss
over the flow.
and that term is to the absolute value.
Delta Q here is the flow correction.
So what this shows us is that there is
two terms that we're going to need to
solve for in order to find the flow
correction. The first is going to be the
head loss and the second will just be
the head loss over the flow.
The problem already tells us to ignore
minor losses and assume that the Hazen
Williams equation is valid for head
loss.
So if we pull the Hazen Williams
equation out of our reference manual, we
can see that it's the following.
There is a form of Hazen Williams given
in chapter 1 of the environmental
reference manual that is laid out in
terms of head loss. Head loss is going
to be given as x * l
over c to the 1.852
* d to the 4.87
and that whole term is going to be
multiplied by q also raised to the
1.852.
In this case, in the reference manual,
we can see that based on our units given
in the problem, our x value is going to
be 10.44.
So let's add the head loss as a term
in this table above to solve for since
we can see that all of the other values
C, D,
Q, and L are provided by this table.
Now, before we do any calculations,
there's one more thing we need to do,
and that's make sure that each of our
flows is either positive or negative.
So, we're going to call this step 1.5 at
the top and assume a convention of
clockwise flow being positive and
counterclockwise flow being negative.
Let's look at the information given in
the table and apply it to the figure in
order to figure out which pipes have a
positive flow and which pipes have a
negative flow. So we can see that A to B
is given a 1500 gall per minute flow
rate.
If we know that we have 2500 gallons per
minute coming in at this point and
1,250 coming out here,
then we can see that the direction is
going to be clockwise or positive from
the inflow across A and B. Now, if
there's 1,500
coming into B from A and 1250 coming
out, we know that means there has to be
another 250 going to C.
And we can tell based on the pipe
network table again that that is
correct. So, this direction will also be
positive.
Coming back to point A for a second,
we can also see that the table gives the
flow in pipe a D as 1,000. So if we draw
this as such and see a,000 going through
pipe A D,
we can see that we have a,000 coming to
point D and 750 leaving. That means that
another 250
has to be continuing back up to point C.
Since this direction is
counterclockwise, A to D is going to be
negative
and D to C is also going to be negative.
That 250 and that 250 finalizes our
numbers to show that we have 2500
gallons per minute going in. and a total
of 2500 gallons per minute exiting as
well.
So going back over to our table, we can
see that A to B is going to be positive,
B to C is going to be positive, C to D
is going to be negative, and A to D is
going to be negative. So this will help
us as we solve out the Hazen Williams
equation. So let's solve Hazen Williams
for our first branch in the pipe
network. The term X is going to be given
as 10.44
based on the units provided according to
the reference manual. So for pipe AB the
equation for the Hazen Williams head
loss value will be 10.44 44 * the length
of 50 ft
over
120 raised to 1.852*
diameter of 12 in
raised to the 4.87.
And all of this times the flow of
positive,500
gpm
raised to the 1.852.
And if we solve this out,
we will see that our answer is just
about 0.312
for the head loss in pipe AB.
So I'll write that in up here.
[Music]
And our next term that we can add to
this table will just be the head loss
divided by Q
since that's the other term
that we need to figure out the Hardy
cross flow correction value. So, HF over
Q
equ=
0.312
over,500
gallons per minute.
And that is going to come out to 0.0000
28.
[Music]
The next step would be to solve the
Hazen Williams equation for head loss
and head loss over Q
for terms BC, CD, and AD. As well, to
save time in the video, I'm going to
write down the next terms answers here.
If you'd like, you can pause it and
calculate them yourself before I fill
them in.
Now that we have all of the head losses
for each pipe in the network, we can sum
them up and solve for the Hardy cross
flow correction factor.
So the sum of all the head losses is
going to come out to -4
217 according to our convention.
And
the sum of the head losses over the flow
is going to come out to 0.
59. Solving for the flow correction
vector,
we can see that it's a negative value
times
4.217
over
1.85
times the absolute value of
0.0059. 0059
which is going to come out to just about
386.3
of which of our answers given here the
closest is 390.
So this problem is super tedious to
solve but it's not super difficult to
solve. I actually really hope that you
don't ever come across one of these on
the PE exam just because of how long it
may take to calculate Hazen Williams
four times in a row and fill out the
table here. But if you do, you can see
here that all you need is the equation
for the Hardy Cross method, the equation
for the Hazen Williams head loss, and an
understanding of how to set positive and
negative conventions in a given pipe
network. From there, you'll assign your
flows as positive and negative.
Calculate each head loss using the Hazen
Williams equation. Then sum those values
up and perform one iteration of the
Hardy Cross flow correction using the
terms that you solved for. And that's
it.